So what I'm showing you here is sort
of a software engineering road map to synthesizing a
complex system. So what we're going to do is, first
we're going to go from specification to implementation. And the
figure shows a workflow in building a complex
system. In particular, what I focused on is a
TCP/IP network protocol stack using this methodology of the
design cycle that I presented. So I start with.
What is called an Abstract Behavioral Spec. Now this is where we use this IoA
automata. And this abstract behavioral spec is
where we describe the functionality of the subsystem
in terms of requirements. And we are
presenting the high level logical specification of the
components and the specification is really talking
about the properties that we want, the subsystem
to adhere to. Not how it is going to
be accomplished, or how, how it is going to be executed,
but the properties that it has to adhere to.
For example, in the protocol. If we desire that the
package should be delivered in order, that's a property
that we want for the subsystem. Those are the behavioral
properties that are going to express using the I/O Automata. Another
behavioral specification properties that you can have are things like,
well, on every packet there should be an acknowledgement. That's
another property that you want the protocol to have. You
can express that using the I/O Automata. So the abstract
behavioral spec is simply and lends itself to deriving properties
about the behavior of the system. Not the execution, but
the behavior of the system, such as [UNKNOWN] and so
on. It is not executable code, even though I told
you that the syntax of I/O Automata is similar to C,
it's not executable code. But the interesting thing
is that Once you've expressed the abstract behavioral
properties, you can actually verify whether the behavioral
specification meets the properties that you want in
the sub-system. So proving that the behavioral spec
meets the properties is facilitated by the I/O
Automata theoretical framework. That's the nice thing about
this behavioral spec. Once we know that the
behavioral spec is meeting the properties that we set
up for the subsystem, then we are ready to roll
our sleeves and go down the path of implementing
the behavioral properties. Next step in the process is getting
to a concrete behavioral spec. We get to this
concrete behavioral spec from the abstract behavioral spec through a
whole set of refinements to this abstract behavioral spec.
For instance, the refinement could be that, if I have
a Q Data structure. I want first come, first
serve property, how do I make sure that the abstract
behavioral spec adheres to the additional execution condition that
I want of first come, first serve. Those are the
kinds of things that I can do, and refining
the abstract behavioral spec to get a concrete behavioral spec.
This is still not code, but it is closer
to code than abstract behavioral spec. It's closer to implementation.
And from the concrete behavioral spec, we get to
the actual implementation using OCaml as the programming language.
And between the implementation and the concrete behavioral spec,
there is not a whole lot of difference. It
is really the scheduling of the operations that we
want in the concrete behavioral spec that is being
detailed. when we go from this step to this
step and producing OCaml code, which is finally an executable
code for the original abstract behavioral Spec
that we started with. I already mentioned
some of the reasons why they chose
OCaml as the implementation vehicle. Functional programming language,
formal semantics, and it also leads to
compact code. High level operations and data structures
and also it has features like automatic
garbage collection, automatic memory allocation, and marshalling and
unmarshalling of arguments. This is very important because
I mentioned that we're going towards Building a complex
system, from a specification, using a component based
design approach, which means that we're going to take
these components and mesh them together, just like
you take Lego blocks to build a toy. Similar
to that we are taking components and meshing
them together to get the complex implementation, and when
we do that We are necessarily going across different
components and when we go across different components you
have to adhere to the interface specifications of those
components which means you have to marshall the arguments
and unmarshall the arguments when you go between these
components and Ocaml Has facilities for doing these kinds
of marshalling and unmarshalling built into the language framework
which makes it an ideal vehicle for Component-based design.
And also the programmability of Ocaml is similar to C and the definition of the
primitives in OCaml makes it a good vehicle for developing verifiable code.